>> Jeanine: PRESIDENT BIDEN IS
LOOKING TO REBOOT HIS AGENDA TO
TRY TO SAVE HIS FAMILY AND
PRESIDENCY.
BIDED NO ROAD TESTING IS
ECONOMIC MESSAGE WITH A TRIP TO
OHIO TODAY AND FOR GOOD REASON.
HIS APPROVAL IS DISMAL IN A NEW
QUINNIPIAC POLL, JUST 37% OF
VOTERS THINK HE'S DOING A
GOOD JOB.
AND INFLATION TOPPING THE LIST
OF ISSUES AMERICANS ARE MOST
WORRIED ABOUT.
BY THEN DOING HIS BEST TO PUT A
POSITIVE SPIN.
>> WE ARE BRINGING MANUFACTURING
JOBS BACK.
BETTER JOBS AND LOWER PRICES.
>> Jeanine: ALL RIGHT, I WILL
START WITH YOU, DANA.
WITH PRESIDENT BIDEN AT 37%
APPROVAL RATING -- DOES ANYONE
BELIEVE THAT HE COULD TURN THIS
AROUND?
>> Dana: I KEEP TRYING TO SEE
WHAT THEY ARE GOING TO ANNOUNCE
OUT OF THE STATE OF THE UNION TO
TRY TO MAKE US BELIEVE THAT
THERE IS A PIVOT COMING.
AND EVERY DAY, NOTHING EVER
COMES OF IT.
I THINK THAT HIS TRIP TO OHIO
AND TO VIRGINIA ARE CONSIDERED
THESE "DO NO HARM" TYPE OF TRIPS
PER THE CANTER OF THE DEMOCRATS
IN THE STATES ANYMORE THAN THEY
ALREADY ARE.
HE LOST OHIO BY EIGHT, VIRGINIA
WITH A SIMILAR AMOUNT.
ARIZONA, GEORGIA, NEW HAMPSHIRE,
AND NEVADA.
IF YOU WERE TO GO TO THOSE
STATES, THOSE ARE THE SWING
STATES WHERE THE SENATE RACES
REALLY MATTER.
HE WOULD BE SEEN HELPING
DEMOCRATS, BUT HE'S NOT GOING
THERE.
WHY NOT?
BECAUSE HE WOULD BE SEEN AS
HURTING SOMEONE LIKE
SENATOR MARK KELLY OR RAPHAEL
WARNOCK.
REMEMBER WHAT HAPPENED WHEN HE
WENT TO GEORGIA WITH
KAMALA HARRIS?
ALL OF A SUDDEN STACEY ABRAMS
COULDN'T ATTEND A SPEECH ON THE
MOST IMPORTANT ISSUE THAT SHE
WORKED ON ON VOTING RIGHTS.
I THINK THAT THEY ARE HAVING HIM
GO OUT ON THE ROAD BECAUSE IF
YOU REMEMBER A MONTH AGO, THEY
SAID THE PROBLEM WITH HIS
APPROVAL RATINGS IS THAT THEY
DON'T COMMUNICATE WELL ENOUGH
AND HE WANTED TO GET OUT, SEE
THE PEOPLE, AND THAT IS WHAT
THEY ARE TRYING TO DO HERE.
WE WILL SEE IF IT WORKS.
>> Jeanine: JESSE, LET'S
ASSUME HE IS TALKING ABOUT
INFRASTRUCTURE IN OHIO.
DO AMERICANS WANT TO HEAR ABOUT
INFRASTRUCTURE?
>> Jesse: WE ONLY LIKE
INFRASTRUCTURE WHEN THE
CONSTRUCTION IS FINISHED.
WE HATE CONSTRUCTION DURING
CONSTRUCTION.
IT'S JUST A BUNCH OF TRAFFIC AND
HAMMERING BID WE LIKE WHEN THE
POLITICIAN COMES AND CUTS THE
RIBBON.
NONE OF THE MONEY HAS BEEN
DISBURSED.
THEY HAVE A PUT A SHOVEL IN THE
DIRT.
SO WHAT, IT'S GOING TO BE THREE,
TEN, 15 YEARS LATER BEFORE
ANYTHING HAPPENS?
>> Greg: WE WILL BE DEAD!
>> Jesse: YOU PROBABLY WILL BE
WITH THE WAY YOU EAT.
YOU CAN SAY WHICH IS HER UP, BUT
INFLATION KILLS THAT.
IT'S REAL CHOPPY.
YOU CAN SAY JOBS ARE UP, BUT NOT
TO WHERE THEY WERE BEFORE COVID
STARTED.
ALL HE DOES IS TALK ABOUT THE
GOOD THINGS AND HE DOESN'T EVER
ADDRESS THE BAD THINGS.
SO WHEN THE AMERICANS HERE THAT,
THEY THINK THIS GUY IS CLUELESS.
>> Jeanine: INFLATION -- DOES
THIS GUY HAVE ANY CREDIBILITY?
DO WE HAVE ANY HOPE?
>> Greg: INFLATION AS AN ISSUE
IS LIKE A CRIME IN THAT IT
BECOMES A RESULT OF THIS
CHANGING CLASS DIVISION.
THE LEFT AND MEDIA AND POLITICS
AND ENTERTAINMENT, TO THEM,
INFLATION JUST MEANS THAT IT'S
LIKE $65 INSTEAD OF 55.
OR THEIR LIFT TICKETS JUST WENT
UP A BIT, BUT THAT'S NOT GOING
TO STOP THE RICH DEMOCRATS FROM
SKIING.
BASICALLY INFLATION IS AN
ABSORBABLE COST FOR A RICH
LIBERAL FANTASY.
THEY CAN PAY IT.
THE SAME WAY THEY CAN PROTECT
THEMSELVES FROM CRIME.
MEANWHILE, EVERYBODY ELSE CAN.
EVERYBODY ELSE WHO ACTUALLY
LOOKS AT PRICES ON PRODUCTS,
TRIES TO GET STUFF ON SALE.
INFLATION ISN'T SOME INVISIBLE
BYPRODUCT OF BIG GOVERNMENT.
>> Jeanine: SHOULDN'T IT BE
MAKING SOME CHANGES IN THE
WHITE HOUSE?
WHO SHOULD THEY GET RID OF?
RON KLAIN?
>> Geraldo: FIVE A DIFFERENT
TAKE ON BIDEN AND OHIO, WHICH
IS -- I WENT TO CLEVELAND.
A PORT CITY WHERE THEY USED TO
BUILD THOUSAND FOOT LONG SHIPS,
A BIG STEEL MILL UP THE RIVER
THERE.
THIS ANNOUNCEMENT WAS
ELECTRIFYING TODAY THAT HE'S
GOING TO SPEND $2 BILLION OF THE
BUILD BACK BETTER -- NOT THE
BUILD BACK BETTER, THE
INFRASTRUCTURE FOR A SUBMARINE
CONSTRUCTION BASE THERE.
THREE, 4,000 PERMANENT
EMPLOYEES.
LORRAINE WAS A PLACE WHERE MANY
CAME AFTER WORLD WAR II TO BUILD
SHIPS.
THIS IS A GREAT THING FOR THE
GREAT LAKES IF IT HAPPENS.
TO JESSE'S POINT, IT'S WELL
TAKEN.
IT'S ONE THING TO TALK ABOUT IT.
BUT PEOPLE ON MY RAD